hey what's going on everybody I'm here
in Albany New York now as some of you
know on my late-night Saturday shows
things get a little weird and every now
and then I do something called it
dance-off where I bring people onstage
and I play a song and they dance behind
me this particular night in Columbus
Ohio
we had a soccer mom go wild I hope you
like it
comedian Josh wolf calm for tour dates
check it out also San Francisco at the
end of the month Saturday Late Show I'm
gonna be taping the full set and
releasing it only right on here so if
you live up there come out to the show
if not I hope you enjoy this video come
get you mom hey man it's gonna be great
here we go
she took the glasses off because she
doesn't want to see what she's about to
do you
[Applause]
my fire
[Music]
[Applause]
man
[Music]
I'm going to bring three people on stage
what'll happen is is all three of them
will answer the same three questions and
then each one of them will dance one
verse you guys will vote somebody off
the island and then two people will have
a dance-off to win their server 50 bucks
all right we can do for tonight let's do
four you want to come up for Nia's hand
on this side of me I want to set up one
rule right up front because there was
one show I didn't set up this rule and
things got a little awkward rule number
one there's no touching me one show
we're gonna go down one at a time I'm
gonna ask you three questions so come on
up here first what's your name
I'm Carolyn Carolyn okay Carolyn on a
scale of 1 to 10 and by the way guys I'm
getting kinda high Carolyn on a scale of
1 to 10 what would you say one being
Elaine from Seinfeld and 10 being
Michael Jackson before the are you rate
yourself with a dancer 1 through 10 Oh
your husband says 3 to 2 now I like
here's what I like about that and that
strategy is cuz then when you're 4
people be like oh she was a [ __ ] 4
right all right so tell me now I need to
know it one word I'm gonna be asking you
all you guys the same question one word
to describe your dance style
some people say athletic some people
have said aggressive some people have
said sexy one word to describe your
dance style unique unique alright
and what is the name of your best dance
move l8 ok there we go
here can I have that mic there thank you
very much Cara Lee everybody hi Carolyn
step over here Carolyn is a - she's a
her dance style is unique and her best
dance move is called Elaine come on up
here you stoned [ __ ] I'm stoned
oh really ok
help me man hit me hit me I'm stoned -
we're good okay man what is your name
tater tater I could have guessed that
tater no you said it once already got it
yeah
boy is it tater tater oh that would be
great if your name is tenth it is now
all right tater so tater oh my god he's
giving you he's giving you a little
preview guys tater tell me on a scale of
one to ten how would you rate yourself
as a dancer I'll give myself a good
solid seven
why did you sound like why did you sound
like shaggy from scooby-doo give myself
a seven scoop we're on the case man
we're where are they okay I'll do the
jokes I've had one word that would
describe your dance style one word
ginger yeah and what is the name of your
best dance moves I don't know I guess
ginger moves just like ginger don't show
everybody that don't smoke don't blow
your load right now tater
well hold it in for a minute yeah yeah
that's probably all you got you're right
okay come on over here man 10:07 his
dance style is ginger and your dance
move is ginger ginger moves
birthday girl come on up here I mean
you've been smiling the whole time I
love it
what's your name I'm Angie hi Angie how
are you I'm good good cocktails so am i
right huh about a few cocktails some all
right okay here we go okay
I like tater you're the cheerleader up
here that I like that yeah Carolyn's
like I'm gonna stand afar the [ __ ] away
rate yourself as a dancer six all right
one word to describe your best your
dance style one word to describe against
out Oh guys you've had a little while to
take the answer so I know and that's
what I was trying honestly was up here
thinking okay I can do all that you do
okay it just depends on what we're I
know so you you have not answered the
question at all I don't even know what
the [ __ ] you're talking about
all right I gotta tell you I'm looking
forward to this one you go my friend
what is your name man I'm rich rich yeah
rich has got some [ __ ] dimples
alright alright rich man the 1 through
10 rate yourself as a dancer I'm gonna
get myself a fare 6 a fare 6 alright hey
listener and in case anybody was getting
too twisted rich is a cool mother [ __ ]
come on go ahead and give myself a 6
yeah like you were about to sing me an
R&B song oh [ __ ] Oh back I'm about to
give you 6
[Music]
alright one word to describe your best
thing style pelvic pump
[Applause]
and this man listen listen listen he's
it wrong to say I just got a little
tingle in my nono spot
so pelvic pump is your dance style what
is the name of your best dance move come
on rich we'll call it the rich inator
Richard and listen everybody that's rich
rich is the six but I don't think so his
dance style as the pelvic pump and his
best dance move is the originator I'm
going to play a song you're going to do
interpretive dance that means you don't
have to be a good dancer
that just means feel the music feel the
music my man you're up tato you're first
but wait tater you don't don't don't
dance yet don't dance yet I want to just
get to let you all hear the song you'll
be dancing to you
don't dance yet man you're giving away
your moves just listen to the song for a
second yeah justjust listen ready you
this is all your dancing too first shut
don't move don't dance yet I'll tell you
what you're gonna dance over here when
your dance okay Blair Witch yourself
hater come on out here man
use hey just remember people reward
effort they reward ingenuity just feel
the music listen to the words tailor
Europe man how like is that your start
position okay all right good yeah
you look like you're about to do a cheer
Oh
[Music]
my fight
I need that way
ten everybody uh Santa Angie just
remember the crowd rewards effort just
feel the music the fact that you guys up
here so much respect the balls it takes
to come up here so much is fun no joke
man that's not easy to do a lot of
people like [ __ ] no no no no and you
guys it's not easy so respect you cannot
fail you've already won you've already
won you've already won here we go all
right
tater you can fail but everybody else
nobody else
when I say
[Music]
hey y'all head you everybody picnic rich
get on up here
bridge bridge bridge bridge bridge
really
this isn't prison [ __ ] turn
around
oh yeah you can suck dude start boy band
I like oh yeah listen everybody Nicholas
Shay's gonna rock the [ __ ] for you right
now
this is Knicks long-lost cousin rich
Lachey
taters whispered go hard Matt go hard
head down
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
my thigh
jeez
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
just quick question quick question
anyone besides me got a boner anyone
else not full like a partial I'm sitting
down yeah not I mean your husband is
filming this is that right okay so
listen to me
[Applause]
[Music]
and there you go just effort and energy
give kids let's embarrass
Carolyn then let's embarrass the [ __ ]
out of those little [ __ ]
[Applause]
do some [ __ ] when they watch it they're
like what the [ __ ] mom get in there
Carolyn like you just took your first
hit of ecstasy in its 1994 let's go girl
all right let me start dating Claire
okay here we go Carolyn hey man it's
gonna be great here we go
she took the glasses off because she
doesn't want to see what she's about to
do here we go ready
[Applause]
my fire
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
ah
[Applause]
yeah good tater taters tater you let me
what I do let me tell you one thing
first of all did you miss that
[Applause]
you didn't see that [ __ ] let me tell you
something man how happy you bought
tickets it's a nice show
[Applause]
I don't know what just happened but I'm
gonna check the tape
[Applause]
[Music]
and here's what we do it's up to you
guys you vote the next two people
through
[Music]
Oh
taters smarter than I thought he was so
listen we can do that we can do the name
and buy the clap more we can just
acknowledge probably what two people are
going through and I want to say this to
tater and Angie first of all [ __ ] yeah
all right let me tell you something
missing you're gonna wake up tomorrow
morning and be like I can't but yeah but
in a good way because next time
something like this isn't gonna be that
scary you didn't know you had to show
your titties
well you never have to but
I've been on this earth to know long
enough to know it never [ __ ] hurts
you know it's not a rule but it's not
not a rule you know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's hear one time for tater and Angie
everybody out of here and happy birthday
Angie everybody you can do whatever you
want again the only rule is no touching
me no using me as a prop no touching the
guitar the mic stand
there's a [ __ ] invisible invisable
I'm high
thanks man that's for sure stoner I go
I'm high and he goes it's okay man you
know how you can tell fellow people who
smoke weed because when they say man
there's like seven A's in there don't be
intimidated man you got this Carolyn
just take what you're too girl
[Applause]
geez I
[Music]
[Applause]
we
hot-too
I can't
[Applause]
when
I say
[Applause]
me you tell me why
[Music]
but tell me why he
ah
hi that's it everybody
[Applause]
I'm not gonna lie to you I think I got a
little public pump on my pants
yeah yeah listen rich if you're not here
with somebody you're about to be
yes
I think you're getting laid tonight too
man I hope you gave those kids some
benadryl cuz mama is on fire tonight
oh there grandma yeah that's [ __ ] in the
kitchen
[Applause]
[Laughter]
okay rich
[Music]
[Applause]
and I felt like that was predominantly
women Carol
[Applause]
I think I think cuz I think there's a
pretty clear winner but I'm gonna tell
you this right now and this is that the
reason this ended up being as good as it
did is because big dick rich took it up
a [ __ ] notch and show Carolyn oh I
better do some [ __ ]
so you don't see that without this so
I'm getting both of them 50 bucks thank
you guys so much for coming up she's so
drunk she forgot she can't see
this has been a [ __ ] amazing crowd
[Applause]
holy [ __ ]
almost an hour and forty in and you guys
are still [ __ ] rocking it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]